[Applaudissements]
mes chers amis nous sommes tous là ce
soir
monsieur le premier ministre edouard
balladur que je salue avec bonheur
toujours fidèle à nos rendez vous
essentiel nous sommes là ce soir autour
de laurent wauquiez et d'hervé morin
c'est tout un symbole que les
républicains et les centristes soient là
rassemblés
nous sommes là ce soir autour de valérie
pécresse
notre présidente de région lino france
[Applaudissements]
nous sommes là ce soir avec nos
présidents de groupes parlementaires
christian jacob bruno retailleau nous
sommes là ce soir autour du président de
notre délégation parlement européen
franck proust que je salue et remercie
pour son action
[Applaudissements]
nous sommes là les parlementaires
européens
permettez moi d'en citer trois qui ont
pris la décision de ne pas être candidat
michèle alliot marie qui est là ce soir
rachida dati et renaud muselier pour
saluer le travail qu'ils ont fait au
parlement européen
leur engagement nous sommes là bien sûr
ce soir madame la députée des deux
arrondissements rejoint par le député
voisin claude goasguen 16e et 17e
arrondissements avec les élus de paris
avec les députés et sénateurs
présent si nombreux qui viennent des
quatre coins de métropole et d'outre-mer
chaire viviane je voudrais saluer le
maire du xviie arrondissement de paris
vous reconnaîtrez là une précaution
sénatoriales et l'importance du rôle des
maires dans notre société et je suis
heureux de partager avec vous ce moment
de rassemblement oui mes amis nous
savons nous rassembler quand l'essentiel
est en jeu
quand il s'agit de défendre nos idées et
de nous battre pour conviction
nous voulons partager autour de nos
candidats avec françois-xavier bellamy
huit engagements
je vous propose que nous nous signons le
neuvième engagement c'est à dire de nous
engager de toutes nos forces dans les
dix jours qui viennent pour que cette
liste parce le meilleur score possible
et que nous montrions qu'il n'y a jamais
de fatalité ce sera l'engagement de
paris l'engagement du palais des congrès
ça sera notre engagement collectif
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
permettez moi de faire un clin d'oeil
avec bruno retailleau à nos amis de
groupe de l'union centriste du sénat qui
sont là ce soir
j'y vois un signe de la construction de
ce qui peut être demain comme elle l'est
au sénat une force d'alternance
d'innovation et de progrès et permettez
moi de faire un clin d'oeil un président
de groupe encore plus indépendant que
les indépendants qui nous vient doré
loire philippe ligier que je vois ce
soir nous soutenir ici
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
oui mes chers amis je dois dire que nous
avons rarement vu une campagne se
dérouler dans de telles conditions
en prélude une crise sociale un climat
qu'on a pu qualifier par fouad
insurrectionnel un grand débat
interminable
j ai participé qui a certes montré le
besoin de dialogue de nos compatriotes
mais dont nous nous demandons
objectivement aujourd'hui à quoi at il
servi
[Applaudissements]
à l'issue une parole présidentielle
décalé décalé tout simplement du vécu
réel des français dans nos territoires
la solution à la crise d'identité à la
crise sociale et sociétale que nous
traversons ne peut décidément pas se
réduire à une simple déclinaison de
mesures techniques catégorielles sur le
pouvoir d'achat la fiscalité ou la crise
de la représentation
les français attendent des propositions
fortes et concrètes
mais rien ne sera possible sans cap fixé
son objectif identifier sans fil
conducteur sans l'idée que tout doit
concourir à un grand dessein pour le
pays
cela prendra nécessairement du temps
demandera des efforts mais permettra de
reconstruire une espérance et nous
devons être l'espérance pour notre pays
pour demain
c'est aussi notre responsabilité
[Applaudissements]
il s'agit de s'attaquer aux racines du
mal qui peu à peu ronge notre pays
les racines du mal chers amis elle
s'appelle la sueur fiscalité avec le
taux de prélèvement le plus élevé du
monde
plus de 12 points au dessus de la
moyenne de l'eau c d e
comment voulez vous que la question du
consentement à l'impôt ne soit pas posé
les racines du mal elle s'appelle niveau
de la dépense publique c'est notre
deuxième triste record plus de 56 % de
notre pim
alors monsieur le président de la
république il va falloir nous expliquer
pourquoi avec un tel niveau d'impôts et
un tel niveau de dépenses la france qui
est un pays qui redistribue beaucoup et
depuis longtemps est encore soumis à des
tensions sociales aussi forte et quelles
sont les solutions que vous proposez aux
français pour réduire ces tensions la
solution ne la connaissons
seule la baisse de la dépense publique
permettra de réduire la pression fiscale
est de retrouver des marges pour
améliorer la compétitivité de nos
entreprises
réduire le chômage et garantir le
pouvoir d'achat des français
pourquoi dans ce pays aussi
redistributif nos compatriotes on a de
tels sentiments d'injustice
pourquoi continuer de penser que moins
de riches c'est moins de pauvres alors
que la réalité est autre
le véritable sujet n'est pas qu'il y ait
trop de gens qui gagnent trop d'argent
mais trop de gens qu'ils n'en gagnent
pas assez c'est bien la réalité
[Applaudissements]
les racines du mal
monsieur le maire de versailles que je
salue chez à françois-xavier c'est aussi
la perte du sens du désir de faire
communauté
je dis bien communauté au singulier car
c'est d'une seule communauté nationale
dont il s'agit notre pays s'est
fragmentée une part de plus en plus
importantes de nos compatriotes a le
sentiment d'être abandonnés décroché de
ne plus compter ce sont les oubliés de
la croissance les isoler du numérique
les victimes collatérales de la
mondialisation et de la métropolisation
en dehors d'événements exceptionnels
attentats catastrophes
oui les airs dans cette cérémonie
poignante à l'hôtel des invalides
oui en dehors de ces événements
exceptionnels le sentiment
d'appartenance à une même nation se
dilue dans la défense de plus en plus
individualiste d'intérêts catégoriels ou
communautaires oui pas d'eric péchenard
l'a rappelé je m'inscris
je m'inscris dans l'héritage dans
l'héritage de ce que nous a transmis le
général de gaulle
nous ne pouvons pas accepter de voir
s'effriter notre bien commun pour nous
l'unité de la nation un sens profond
vont le gaullisme
au delà de sa période c'est en fait
cette histoire millénaire que nous avons
en commun et un avenir que nous avons en
partage
le gaullisme le schéma mes chers amis
c'est surtout le contraire du
renoncement
voilà me semble-t-il le sens de notre
engagement ne jamais renoncer être
debout se dire qu'il n'ya jamais de
fatalité c'est dans ce contexte que nous
abordons cette fin de campagne des
élections européennes l'europe cherche
joseph daul vous l'avez dit est un enjeu
majeur
un enjeu majeur pour l'avenir de notre
pays et l'avenir de notre pays est
tellement dépendants de l'avenir de
l'europe
faut bien se le dire il n'y aura pas
demain une europe prospère dans une
europe en déclin c'est enjeux dépassent
toutes les batailles d'ego et les
rivalités de personnes
je m'inscris pour ma part dans ce
mouvement ou sensibilité sont diverses
au parcours sont différents mais l'enjeu
européen impose notre rassemblement
autour de la liste menée par
françois-xavier bellamy agnès evren et
arnaud danjean
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
en fait en fait cher valérie nous
adversaires politiques ou voulu fixer la
règle d'un jeu truqué
vous êtes pro européen alors vous n'avez
pas le choix
vous devriez voter république en marche
vous êtes sceptique sur l'europe alors
honoré comme choix que de voter
rassemblement national au fort emmanuel
macron a choisi marine le pen et veut
imposer de rassemblement national comme
seul opposant et cette stratégie au fond
fait le miel de marine le pen c'est en
quelque sorte un jeu de rôle à 2
tellement dangereux pour notre pays
[Applaudissements]
sa fille en 1985 monsieur le premier
ministre à stratégie de françois
mitterrand fait remonter le front
national
pour affaiblir la droite et le centre
mais attention à ces stratégie du pire
et n'est pas machiavel qui veut alors je
refuse cette vision manichéenne
je refuse à ce match à deux qu'ils ont
décidé de jouer ensemble
je refuse le scénario qu'ils ont
imaginée il ya une autre voie
cette voie c'est la nôtre c'est celle
des républicains est les centristes
ensemble ne l'oublions pas nous sommes
les formations des fondateurs de
l'europe
nous sommes au parti populaire européen
premier parti du parlement européen
cherche joseph nous portons une vision
de l'europe qui protège cher arnaud
danjean qui affronte les difficultés au
lieu de les contourner qui refusent le
fédéralisme d1 et l'euroscepticisme des
autres notre projet est ambitieux
réaliste courageux fidèles à notre
histoire
emmanuel macron élu président de la
république avait prétendu être l'un des
leaders de l'union européenne
regardons aujourd'hui l'axé
franco-allemand est tellement malmené
que dans un interview ce soir la
chancelière allemande et je cite ces
mots pas en des relations conflictuelles
avec emmanuel macron jamais la relation
franco allemande n'a jamais autant était
atteinte
je vous mets en garde si nous ne parions
pas sur cette relation franco allemande
alors c'est pas simplement la relation
entre deux pays
c'est l'avenir
à force le rayonnement de toute l'europe
qui est en cause
rien que pour ce motif là où devait
soutenir notre liste renforcer le ppe et
demain c'est la seule manière dont nous
pèserons au parlement européen et dans
les institutions européennes
oui contre frak entre tracts cet axe
franco-allemand malmené une union
européenne structurer un break site qui
nous ankylose aucune avancée
perspectives sur les grands sujets qui
fragilise notre cohésion de l'europe de
la défense la défense des intérêts
économiques à la crise migratoire c'est
vrai en europe ne va pas très bien par
beaucoup de renoncement l'europe ne va
pas très bien quand elle est incapable
d'apporter des réponses solidaires la
crise migratoire et au co développement
l'europe ne va pas très bien à vouloir
s'occuper de tout alors qu'on lui
demande de gérer l'essentiel
l'europe ne va pas très bien quand elle
assiste et nous l'avons revu hier
cher jean pierre val et cher qu'ici
encore bouscatel assis sur le banc de
touche à l'implosion du moyen orient
mes chers amis aucune tribune aucun
discours ne fera disparaître l'échec de
notre politique européenne
je parle de l'échec de notre politique
européenne celle de françois hollande
celle d' emmanuel macron depuis sept ans
et la perte d'influencé de la france
quel leadership vouloir incarner quand
on est fâché avec la moitié des états
membres et qu'on a divisé l'europe en
deux de danse à syracuse
d'un côté le mal et de l'autre côté le
bien ça n'est pas notre vision de
l'europe des 27
oui quel quidam chip monsieur le
président de la république vouloir
incarner que nous sommes incapables de
tenir nos premiers engagements sur la
réduction des déficits
quel leadership monsieur le président de
la république vouloir incarner quand la
france projette depuis des mois ces
images de désordres et de violences au
reste du monde
peut-être vous étonnez vous que
j'interroge le président de la
république mais j'ai le sentiment que
derrière il n'y a jamais dire pas grand
chose alors mes chers amis je vais vous
le dire l'idéal européen doit rester
intacte seule une renfort peut prétendre
jouer un rôle dans le concert des
nations
salut nos renforts peuvent tenter de
fixer des règles du jeu ces règles à ces
monstres que sont venues les gars femme
qui bouleverse les règles de l'économie
mondiale chers amis c'est notre neuvième
engagement mobilisons nous avec nos
différences de sensibilité et vous bien
que rien ne serait pire pour notre pays
cano man's land entre la république en
marche et le rassemblement national
et pourtant c'est cette musique qu'on va
vous distiller dans les dix jours qui
viennent alors je voulais vous dire que
je partage avec françois-xavier bellamy
conviction la nécessité de retrouver nos
racines d'être les héritiers des
bâtisseurs de cathédrales des
physiocrates et des lumières d'être
les héritiers des soldats de l'an 2 de
ceux de verdun d'être les héritiers de
le corbusier des commandos qui faire
celle de nos soldats ce soir aux
avant-postes dans la nuit du sahel ou
dans le ciel dorian c'est ça c'est ça
nos valeurs oui assumer notre histoire
européenne
c'est celle de l'espérance de monnaie de
schumann de gasperi c'est celle de la
volonté du général de gaulle et du
chancelier adenauer de valéry giscard
d'estaing des mucci de chirac et de
colle c'est la volonté de nicolas
sarkozy dans la tempête financière de
oui je crois une europe des valeurs je
crois une europe qui imagine son avenir
dans la diversité des nations en
l'engageant nous et je vous propose un
chemin passons par les sommets comme le
disait le général de gaulle c'est
généralement moins encombré et bien je
vous propose par les sommets qui sont
moins encombré de soutenir notre lice
pour que vive l'europe et que vive la
france
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]